hey francis do you need new investment
ideas no thanks i've got all my cash
tied up in venezuelan crypto ah how is
gringo coin doing it's pronounced green
coin my portfolio is now worth a billion
venezuelan bolivars and that's about
three quid then uh
you're right i should have got new
investment ideas well if you want to
take back control of your finances then
fortune and freedom is for you it was
founded by nigel farage who has over 40
years of experience in finance and
politics fortune and freedom is
published by south bank investment
research and is for the investor looking
to access a wide range of informed
opinions on lots of different investing
opportunities their brilliant newsletter
covers everything from causes and the
impact of inflation to the rise of
cryptocurrencies gold investing and much
more besides through the daily news
commentary and special reports fortune
and freedom can give you more confidence
in making informed decisions about what
to do with your money simply go to
fortune and freedom dot com that's
fortune and freedom dot com and sign up
for a free newsletter that will help
your money work for you the link is in
the description
uh so we've got a situation now i think
where
the hard-working core of the countries
which i love and respect
is being let down by this unaccountable
pool of
westminster reverse darwinist sort of
creatures who are supposed to be holding
the civil service to account
[Music]
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster i'm constantine and this is a
show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people we
are delighted to say that our guest
today is a businessman and a former
chairman of southampton football club
rupert lowe welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me it's great to
have you on listen our uk viewers i'm
sure particularly the football fans and
one that will be very familiar with you
uh but we have a big international
audience who may be less familiar so
tell everybody first of all who are you
how are you where you are and what has
brought you to be sitting in this chair
talking to us well i'm my name's rupert
lowe i was born in oxford in the
reactive hospital
i'm a provincial lad
i basically was brought up on a farm
where my father was a farmer i'm a
passionate farmer i love farming it's
the one thing i think
uh is keeps everybody honest you can't
you can't
cheat nature
she keeps us all humble so then i uh i
was educated at the dragon school which
is a fantastic school uh it's less
fantastic now it's like everything i
used to crush my school at rugby like at
lifetime like a lot of these schools
it's become woke
then i went to radley college which is
again uh in in local to oxford and then
i went to reading university
after which i went into the city uh
because my father has been married many
times and i didn't get onto one of my
stepmothers so i found my way into the
city as i say i had very little
uh
contact to call on i just went into the
city found my way
ended up commodity broking then stopped
broking then i went uh to japan to work
for bearing securities
so i was phillips and drew bearing
securities morgan grenfell
and then i left morgan grenfell in 96
and took over as chairman of a company
which i'd rescued which i was investor
in called secure retirement
and we did a reverse takeover of
southampton football club i was going to
build the stadium which i did but i
ended up getting involved in the
football as well because i i'm a
reasonably competitive tennis player
a hockey player i carried on playing
hockey that i was 56
played football at the dragon school
even though most
of the football pundits claim i'm a i'm
a hockey and rugby supporting or i was
rugby sporting chairman
um and but during my time with
southampton i've continued with other
businesses so i've got a wide experience
of insurance
i've got businesses in contracting so
data and mechanical electrical
contracting
i've got a business which does heat air
source heat pumps
uh i i i basically i'm an entrepreneur i
like to think and i and i what i love
is i love the british people who are
creative entrepreneurial hard working
and left their own devices they will
deliver a fantastic outcome
so the thing i've become frustrated with
is that we've got far too much statism
far too much oppression far too much
regulation far too much state so
you know i'm keen now at the age of 64
to
try and use my experience to change that
to get the people of this country to
realize how talented they are
gain self-confidence we're obviously now
free of this
post-war experiment with a sort of
global europe
uh which i thought brought with it a
great deal of injustice and unfairness
and i think the people of europe will
will suffer long term and we will
benefit from brexit as a result of being
a free sovereign nation
so so pretty much that's me i uh i still
work reasonably hard
[Music]
i still play a bit and
i still enjoy life which is the most
important thing that is a very important
thing and one of the things that strikes
me about you is you have experience of
managing big things you have experience
of working on big projects and this is
something that in the time francis and
i've been doing the show i've noticed
how my thinking has changed and my
attitude has changed just running this
small business you know there's a six or
seven of us however many of us there are
and that already changes the mindset
so and one of the things that strikes me
particularly about our politicians is
very few of them
actually have
experience of running big things i mean
look at the current prime minister by
the time this goes out he may no longer
be prime minister but but let's say he
still is
this isn't someone who has experience of
running a huge institutional
organization and they're suddenly in a
position to run the whole country what
do you make of the way that we are
administered and governed in this
country well i i think again people the
worst thing that ever happened was the
televising was televising parliament and
it's turned some very average people
into uh sort of media
i wouldn't say stars but they're sort of
they're full of media attention
uh every word they say has listened to
and i think the misapprehension of the
public is they assume that because they
are part of this westminster elite that
they're able people and that when
they're in number 10 they know what
they're doing
well
don't assume they know any more than you
do because they don't
many of them as you say have had no
experience of running a company no
experience of navigating the vagaries of
public company like you know limited
liability
of credit risk of collecting vat
national insurance pensions gift
wrapping it delivering it to the state
all of the risk that comes with being a
director you know people assume being a
director is a is all upside it's
actually in modern britain there's a
hell of a lot of downside to it
so i think i i think
people in westminster it's become a
bubble
the selection processes that were
followed by blair and cameron have meant
that we've we've got less able people so
the gene pool is weak
it's almost like we've got reverse
darwinism that would certainly look it
makes sense when you look at boris
johnson yeah and you know you look at
the decisions they've been making uh uh
which you know and sometimes now in the
past one that it's all seemed to make
sense now i sometimes i don't know about
you but i i sort of wake up in the
morning and i think why does nothing
make sense anymore
and the answer is because we've got
people who don't know what they're doing
leading us so you've got westminster
that's the the gene pool for our leaders
supported by a civil service which let's
face it over brexit was at complete odds
with the with with the electorate who
voted to leave and it took to leave
europe and effectively it took
four years before we managed to get
ourselves out of europe thanks to the
brexit party nigel farage
and and people who basically accuse the
state of not respecting their masters
who are the voters
so i i honestly think we've got this
disjoint between
those people who are leading us and
those people who are working very hard
in the economy
and for me this was exemplified on
monday when
lord agnew of olton resigned
whose government minister
over the bounce-back loan uh fraud
that's happening so again the state has
been pursuing thanks to qe buying it's
getting harnessed
as i call it quantitative easing uh
basically printing money in taxpayers
name and buying their own bonds and then
effectively liquefying the economy by
giving this money to people in bounce
back loans sybil's loans and other
centrally planned state support which i
again i'll just interrupt you there
rupert because there's there's a lot of
people including a lot of economists who
go what's the problem we can just print
money and there's going to be no
problems monetary theory what's wrong
with this where does water flow
downhill and this is going to flow
downhill right we have not yet seen the
effects of quantitative easing and they
they are coming
and they will come and everybody will
regret the fact that we've done it
uh if you look at if you look at so just
finishing off on on that you saw
uh theodore agnew resigned and he
resigned for a very good reason a very
honest straight guy and what you saw is
you've got this i have this image of
these
bounce back loans which were given no
checks were made or not enough checks
you know they don't really understand a
lot of these people get dishing these
out the concept of limited liability
companies that you know if you
if you trade with a company that's
insolvent you can lose everything well
if you give money to companies that are
insolvent or haven't been trading or
people who aren't honest you won't get
it back
and under the limited liability
situation they just walk away and you
end up with a debt which is again a
taxpayer debt
meanwhile on the other side of that
you've got all these hard-working people
you know my old constituents in the west
midlands people up north
all the people who run businesses still
collect the taxes pay the taxes they
have hmrc on their back all the time
chasing them to pay every little penny
using often technicalities to
collect this money off them which takes
possible investment from them which
could be
directed into better use
and meanwhile they're handing this money
out to fraudsters
and there's no accountability i think
they've already written off about four
and a half billion i think the total
bounce back loans are more like 45
billion and goodness knows how much
they're going to write off in the end
that's before we get to the sybil's lens
which is slightly more secure because
you actually got the banks responsible
for 20 of those
so i i i think we've got a situation
where
anything and you've only got to look at
you know the soviet russia you know you
get state central planning it never
works
you need the entrepreneur you need
people to be making decisions that make
sense you need it to be bottom up not
top-down you actually need long-term
investment rather than just short-term
uh
sort of money printing to cover up
cracks
and i and i think everybody the
extraordinary thing is i don't think a
lot of people fully understand it so
there's so busy with their own lives but
actually
quantitative easing is
if you or i did it we'd be in prison
but it's being done in our name by an
unaccountable bank of england and andrew
bailey
who presided over let's face it when he
was at the fca some pretty big disasters
like lcf
uh and
yeah another bureaucrat who's who's
definitely been over-promoted andrew
bailey
uh so we've got a situation now i think
where
the hard-working core of the countries
which i love and respect is being let
down by this unaccountable pool of
uh westminster reverse darwinist uh sort
of creatures
who are supposed to be holding the civil
service to account and that to me is the
most extraordinary it's more it's
extraordinary people aren't more angry
about it
do you think part of the problem roper
is
and we touched on it which is they've
never run anything these politicians but
most of them
they don't even have experience of
ordinary life what they do is they go to
schools then they go to university
normally oxford and cambridge where they
do ppe then they do some type of masters
then they go in to become a political
researcher
you've never experienced the real world
you don't know how the real world works
and if that being the case how are you
then going to go into a position of
power where you're running the real
world well absolutely you can't so the
whole political structure is based on
if you like snakes and ladders in a
little sort of false world where as you
say you you you clamber up the tory
party or the labor ladder
uh you hope you don't upset anybody so
very often you you the people who thrive
are people who learn not to tell the
truth
uh so you end up actually as i say with
this reverse darwinist situation
and most of them i honestly don't think
they bit like boris i don't think
they're that bothered about long term
because as far as they're concerned life
is a game
and it's not a game for a lot of people
you know a lot of people
long term if you look at britain what do
we owe our success to i'll tell you what
i think i mean i think we owe it to the
victorians who were
hard-working
uh if they said they want to do
something they did it they actually
delivered an economy that probably for a
population that we had then whatever it
was 50 60 million was probably arguably
the most successful economy there's ever
been and off the back of that we were
able to do quite a lot of things with
friendly societies with you know
ultimately that's the that's the genesis
of the nhs i think you know the fact we
had all this wealth but if we don't
invest long term and create proper
businesses and actually
proper structures that make sense you
know
printing money
in the end will just be overrun by by by
the asian uh workhouses which basically
become far more productive than us and
it'll happen a bit like the world doing
a 360 degree flip so all everybody here
is very complacent i think because
suddenly we could see this
this this whole thing change and instead
of accepting our currencies these people
are going to say well hang on
these guys are just printing it they've
got nothing behind it
and you know the the war was a big issue
we won the war we basically won the
piece
but sooner or later this
this lack of uh
long-term planning and lack of
leadership by by a proper
elite
is going to
effectively affect everybody's lives and
it's time people started talking about
it i think well one of the things that i
think when you talk about quantitative
easing that i've been saying for quite
some time and i think it was compounded
obviously by the reaction to covid and
the amount of money that was spent on
dealing with that or the perceived
threat or whatever you what you want to
describe it is inflation and you know
we've had people on the show endlessly
to say it's coming it's coming and and
now and then suddenly i was like oh
there's inflation coming and we're like
yeah we told you i think we told you i
think it's here i mean that's what i'm
saying it's here contracting businesses
cop has gone up massively over the last
i mean not seven percent you're talking
50 60 70 percent
you know steel conduits gone up the same
you've got you know labor hasn't gone up
yet but if if heating costs keep going
up people can start demanding more money
for their wages correctly and then you
start to get strikes and you start to
get all the malaise that we got in the
70s it's all happening what were we told
we were told it's transitory this is
this is not transitory this is now
embedded in the economy and it's partly
to do with the fact that we aren't
productive as we used to be
and you can't just
create money out of nothing and expect
it to hold value
it's not linked to anything yeah there's
no gold standard there's no
convertibility to anything it's it's all
on trust
and i've always been brought up to
believe that credit is suspicion asleep
and that's ultimately what you know
as soon as people our trading partners
become suspicious of us the game's over
rupert don't you think it's quite weird
because if we were having this
conversation and let's say jeremy corbyn
won the 2019 general election it would
make sense we're having this con this
conversation under a conservative party
doesn't that strike you as weird it is
bizarre and i think you know boris
johnson's instincts
are actually uh on the whole libertarian
i think he respects the individual
but it seems that he wants to build the
state up and i i think he was even heard
to say that
if the private sector sheds labor don't
worry the state will employ it which
sort of to me was shocking because the
last thing we want we've already got far
too much of a state
we've got far too much ineffective uh
you know government departments in
whether it's hgv licenses whether it's
the passport office whether it's
planning you know i come across all this
stuff you know you can't get any answers
out of the planners
you can't get your passport you can't
get an hgv license you can't get a
shotgun license renewed you know the
whole if you're going to force
regulation on on people you've got to
deliver an efficient service otherwise
get rid of the state get it out of
people's lives and let people interface
freely and make their own call and
that's a bit i feel a bit like that with
regard to covid i mean i i
i think you know i'm not a non-boxer or
an anti-vaxxer but i am a believer in
personal choice i think to have the
state telling you you've got to have an
injection
is against every sort of libertarian
code that you could have that that does
make you an anti-vaccine
i always joke about it being on the
whole not vaccination it's gene therapy
and
because
modern
gene therapy whereas actually um
astrazeneca is the only true vaccine so
again it's very experimental but it's up
to people if people want it that's up to
them if people don't want it it should
be up to them but what i think is
terrible is divisiveness yeah within our
society as a result of that and and you
know the historical
uh parallels to that are pretty
frightening and i and i think it
shouldn't be happening here but on boris
uh is he
is he capable of
of really having any long-term view or
any principal view probably not
quite well this is one of the things i
think you keep referring to which is
long-term versus short-term and i think
i mean i i think democracy is great but
i think it's inevitable that one of the
flaws of democracy is a force is very
short-term thinking because the people
who are in charge are thinking on a
24-hour planning horizon they're not
thinking ahead so with all that doom and
gloom out of the way rupert what do we
do about this
what would you do about this
well one's got to hope that the people
of the britain and i think relative to
the rest of europe we are in a good good
position now because we actually
free sovereign nation and we are
capable of determining our own future so
we have actually now got the power back
in our own hands
so i even if the civil service is
reluctant to accept the will of the
british people so having been given a
vote they voted to leave
um
then then i think we are now
going to see the country relative to
europe prosper and if the right
leadership's in place from the right
long-term planning we still have the
opportunity to do what i think we should
be doing and i think there's a lot to be
uh optimistic about but that involves
doing radical conservative things which
is what a conservative government should
be doing like what not the corbyn uh
conservative government that we've got
well we should be cutting regulation we
should be encouraging entrepreneurs we
should how how do you encourage well you
cut you
you you give people tax breaks for
investment you give people uh you cut
taxes you you allow people to keep the
the product
of their gains you allow people to make
investment uh against you know you how
are we going to pay for all these
interesting social care and then hs and
all of that
because that's what people would like
that takes care of itself if you have a
vibrant
economy where everybody's making money
they're all paying tax
and you know
we know tax if the more you put tax up
the less tax you collect so why do we
keep putting tax up then because
that's the only way they can even hope
to balance the books if you haven't got
long-term investment
you have to keep doing that's actually
the only thing that's kept us going is
qe
and i keep coming back to qe without qe
reality would have would have been would
have been blowing through the corridors
of power but it it doesn't happen
because they don't they don't let it
happen so i'm the answering your
question
cut regulation
uh release the individual uh basically
become
an offshore trading country which we
used to be offshore europe we were
always the balance of power in europe
against either you know germany or
france we always had these continental
conquests we've never wanted to conquer
people we want to trade with them so
what we should do is do what we're best
at trade and and we should be having if
you had a a government and it's it's
apparatus that believed in that you
actually could structure it so that you
release the innate ability of the
british people but we're not going to do
that by increasing national insurance
and pumping it into the nhs with no
reform to the nhs which
like it and again it it's a wonderful
thing for a lot of people but it's got
to be efficient it's got to be reformed
it's it's an inefficient organ
and but no politician is ever going to
touch the nhs at the moment it's become
you know half a cut above itself and
somebody's got to take it in in in in
under control and sorted out
or it's going to bleed us all dry it's
it's going to it's going to kill off
this
entrepreneurial spirit that we should be
able to release which would then allow
us to fund uh
the nhs and other good causes for the
majority of the people in the country
but rupert isn't the problem that we
have a whole generation of politicians
who don't want to make difficult
decisions they don't want to be seen as
unpopular now let's look at thatcher you
may like her you may dislike her you may
not like her vision for the country
number one she had a vision unlike this
lot and number two she was very very
willing to make herself herself
absolutely despised by a certain section
of society yeah i don't think any of
this lot would be would want that and
also likewise just for balance i think i
disagree with him on a lot of things but
tony blair the same now there's a lot to
criticize but he was willing to make
difficult decisions at certain people if
we talk about thatcher uh first did you
raise that she i i was an admirer of
thatcher she's you know her upbringing i
guess that really that wasn't a surprise
not for any other reason that i think
she if you look at britain and i'm
probably older than you guys so i you
probably weren't around i can remember
the 70s where yeah petra was going up
every day inflation was flying you know
there was no investment we had you know
callahan in office having sandwiches
with the trade unions who were running
the country the whole thing was we were
we were a laughingstock
so thatcher took control of it and you
should read a book if you haven't read
it called here today gone tomorrow by
john knott and she would have definitely
lost the election uh because she tried
to make sense of everything and i think
you know this short term uh view that
prevails and you're quite right it does
prevail she would have had a head cut
off if it hadn't been for the falcons
war and so the falklands were invaded
she went in
again
took a dangerous decision won the war
and as a result of that she was
untouchable after that that gave her the
length of time to be able to make change
and i think you've got to give
other people around her credit you know
lawson you've got to give you know other
people who actually
uh if you like empowered
britain and you know i remember going to
singapore to meet the government of
singapore investment corporation
just as all this was happening and they
said this is the first time in
50 years that we've seen
light at the end of the tunnel in
britain we're investing in britain
because we can see it's it's a vibrant
place where
opportunities abounds and people are
going to do well
so
we've now if you like almost gone full
circle and it isn't it depressing that
we've now got a conservative government
that's running the country like corbyn
would have done which
look i agree with you because i look at
this this government i don't know what
they are anymore i look at the labour
party i don't know what they are anymore
they're the only two realistic options
doesn't that mean we're in a political
crisis
well how do we get out of this we've got
a political crisis we've got richard
tyson reform
well done forget the plugin so they're
there he's blocked us on twitter for no
reason whatsoever so you're not you're
banned from disgusting
i have no idea i'm just joking but he
has blocked us on twitter no idea
yeah it's not wise is it fellow
libertarians like you guys you should be
he should be he should be helping i
agree with you but below it's it's an
interesting thing you know we don't meet
many people with your sort of attitude
in this country and as an outsider i've
always wondered about this because as
you say during the victorian era this
was the engine
of
you know of innovation and drive and
creativity in that way
but
what the the values you're talking about
i associate much more with america in
this country in my experience most
people aren't driven to achieve aren't
driven to create and i hope i'm not
slandering the british public because of
course people like that exist too but
why why have we not got quite as much of
that sort of thing that you're talking
about which is starting businesses
creating things i don't know but i i do
think there's a lot more
uh underlying wealth i think the the
english aren't like they're more british
aren't like the americans wealth you
know to show wealth is a is a thoroughly
bad thing and everybody's been brought
up to think that so yeah but there's a
lot more wealth and historical wealth as
well still still residing here
uh and you know i think america a lot of
the wokery and the and and the sort of
i i think terrible things we do import
from america you know a lot of political
correctness and all the other stuff i
mean when are people going to get back
to interfacing with each other and
respecting each other and debating
things even if it's difficult to debate
them
as we you know as as i think we said
earlier the the old labor attitude the
wedgie ben the peter shaw all these
people they they were true
uh if you like british patriots
they had a different view and iris but i
respect it i love listening to the
wedgie ben tapes it's absolutely
fantastic listening for those people who
haven't listened to him it's great you
know he was an honest guy
okay he came from rich family but he was
had a socialist view that's fine
why can't we all debate these things and
have a difference of opinion and then we
get at the truth
but
that's not the way people operate today
it seems that nobody's prepared to
listen to a point of view that they
don't like
again i think partly that comes back to
another of my favorite beefs which is
the bbc
i can't wait to see the back of the bbc
i think the bbc is a
it's a cancer at the heart of britain
it's it's it's well done for putting
that mildly
it actually it's a centrally planned
uh
sort of self-important organization
which
doesn't represent the views of certainly
my old constituency in the west midlands
most of yorkshire and a lot of other
parts of of of the country and it
certainly didn't reflect that over
brexit it was it was completely partisan
which as you know wreath uh uh his
original founding doctrine was it should
be completely impartial and it should
inform entertain and educate does it
inform no does it educate no does it
entertain very definitely not so it
doesn't do any of those things now and
if it's such a national treasure it
should be defunded and it should then
stand on its own two feet like everybody
else and then
if we if they want to spout their woke
views on life and they want to distort
the way in which everybody lives their
lives if people want don't want to
listen to it they can turn it off
but why should we all have to pay 157
pounds 50 or 159 quid whatever it is
to
fund this monster which gives everybody
the wrong impression so in answer to
your question
cut free of the bbc cut free of a lot of
this sort of uh
dogma that gets pushed down people's
throats every day i actually think
you've got an innately productive people
here who could
who could actually make a major
contribution not only to the
the success and wealth of this country
but also it could help europe and the
rest of the world
look at look at it look at what we
invent we most of the good things that
have been invented in the world come
from the uk
so does marmite so it's a bit of a
marmite
the one
the one aspect of the bbc that i will
push back on is this i worry about the
polarization of society i look at
american media you've got msnbc on one
hand fox news on the other never the
twain show me there's people who go on
msnbc they have a conversation with
themselves same with fox news do not
think that the bbc has this power to be
this unifying force
in the center where we can get people on
from libertarian rights you know uh you
know the work left and try and bring
together so we can have a discussion not
just those people people in the center
and everybody i don't think you can
i don't think you can rely on on a
as a broadcaster who has lost its way
because it isn't impartial i think
everybody would accept that
so if it's deficient and the head of the
beast is wrong they always say fish rots
from the head if it's wrong up there
it's never going to be this unifying
agent which which again is desirable if
you could achieve it and i think
when the bbc was founded i think it was
genuinely
a principled organization which did try
to achieve that i think it's become it's
lost its way and
is the right way to achieve what you
what you're hoping to achieve to have a
a license fee which everybody has to pay
regardless of whether they want to or
not and most of the young people if you
talk to
do it do a survey of young people my
children i've got four children under 30
years old
that none of them
watch the bbc they all object to the tv
license why should they have to pay it
they don't use it to get their news i
mean the only justification possibly for
the bbc would be a completely impartial
news service which gave the the british
people
a news which is completely
unaffected or un if you like um unbiased
i'm unbiased completely unbiased and it
hasn't had any pr spin or any you know
anybody sort of
spinning it so it's just pure news so
they can make their minds up about about
life but
i don't see this as a justification for
the music i actually think they create
more division now i think they their
main role in life is to
create division between
the rich and the poor
you know and as lincoln said you don't
make the poor rich by making the rich
poorer so what we've got to do is try
and make the poor richer by
playing a part in a vibrant society that
believes in itself
and bringing them up that way you can't
do it by
creating this sort of division and envy
and the problem we've got now is in the
past you didn't have as much envy
because people didn't know how other
people lived so they yeah they lived
their lives in however they found their
lives to be now you can become a voyager
and you can and let's face it all the
media people are trying to
show how these sort of russian oligarchs
live or how you know the billionaires
live and and and the life they live and
people people
are envious so it's already the end is
already there so we don't want divided
society we want
a society that works together so i don't
think the bbc achieves that now i think
they've
they're an agent for bad not for good
and i personally if people want to watch
it again i'm a great believer in free
choice
uh if you want to charge 160 quid fine
do it by subscription and those people
who want it can pay for it do you think
it's inevitable that it's going to get
defunded i hope so i i think it's
outlived its useful life so
i i'm totally in favor and i make no
bones about it on twitter i it's one of
my favorite uh uh uh subjects and i
think it should go i i think the sooner
it goes the better the sooner we've got
a chance of then releasing this
innate entrepreneurialism of of the
british people well you know what
francis and i are both originally coming
from a position that he articulated
which is the bbc has the potential to be
unifying force but i don't see them
making any attempt to do that uh and and
this the sort of soviet-style state
control thing that you're talking about
is true i mean we look at so so we're in
the podcasting world or making a youtube
show world and we see what they do when
they want to create some podcasts and it
is literally like let's tick some boxes
let's pick people who look the right way
or whatever um and that's not how you
create a good new business or a new
podcast or whatever it has to be on
merit it has to be uh there has to be a
market for it this has to be lots of
people and the bbc isn't constrained by
those things so well any organization
that can spend 100 million on diversity
and inclusion has got to have got it
badly wrong they'll probably get
diversity and inclusion right but then
the content won't be very good that's
that those are the trade-offs um so
become it's interesting the point that
you made about envy because i see a lot
of it and i think
maybe part of it is that there is a
feeling that social mobility has
declined i don't mind you being a
billionaire if i feel that if i work
hard and make the right choices and do
the right things and uh and start a
business and that business does well
then i'm gonna get to a place in my life
where i have what i want and et cetera
et cetera right but i think for a lot of
people particularly with the lack of
innovative spirit as you talk about
there is a feeling in this country where
like if you're born at the bottom
you're kind of stuck there
and there's going to be people the woke
people that you mentioned coming and
telling you that you know you're stuck
there because society is evil and it's
oppressive and it's
you're disenfranchised and by the way
that's true it is true that society
disadvantages certain people more than
others some people are born with more
opportunities than others they have a a
father who has more contacts or they
have money in the bank those things will
help that's true but nature
differentiates by giving some people
somebody a better brain somebody a
better eye somebody whatever so we you
know i'm not born
we're not and i actually think relative
to other countries i've never thought
this is a racist country i i think you
know i i and if you talk to the cab
drivers most of them say well maybe 30
years ago yeah as an indian taxi driver
you might have got some people who are
racist which is horrific but at the end
of the day now i i'm quite proud of this
country i think to beat ourselves up
we are probably the most
fair-minded people uh in the world
to beat ourselves i was completely wrong
so
you know i i i just
i just think we we just need a bit more
confidence
that actually we're we're we're fine and
i with regard to your people who say
they don't get opportunity there's
plenty of opportunity here
and you know if you look at businesses
now look at look at these really
successful businesses most of them were
founded in
2000
2003 2005
and you know they're founded from
nothing
and they've been founded by people
who've got brain power
so in in a way what's happening is and
this is what we're going to make sure
that happens is your brain power is
becoming the currency yes it's true and
what brain power's doing is
with the help of the qe merchants it's
this piece of paper that's backed by
nothing is going to be destroyed
by the ability of the individual to
out-think and out uh you know out design
yeah and out entrepreneur a flat-footed
state that's run by as we say the
reverse darwinists yeah i mean i'm
playing devil's advocate to you but i
know i can't but i can't disagree
because here's the truth if you want to
start something a creative business a
podcast a youtube show design a new
widget or whatever there's never been a
better time the capital you need to do
that it's not like you've got to build a
factory no no it's not like you've got
to make billions of capital investment
to do it in fact with 3d printing
digital printing
you can you can almost now print stuff
that you used to have to have a factory
to me yeah so you know there's huge
innovation taking place the digital
revolution is massive and i think again
it gives people individual opportunity
you don't need to be uh i mean if i've
had any ben
any benefit over other people it's my
education okay so i am lucky that i've
been well educated but i didn't choose
my parents and i didn't choose where i
went to school they did
but other than that i've had to get off
my backside and go and do it myself
completely
and that's quite right i think everybody
should do that now maybe that's a bit of
an advantage but i'll tell you what
there's a lot more people a lot more
clever than i am
so and you know they're brilliant a lot
of people but what you mustn't do is
hold those back yeah but equally you
can't clog up the pause for them to
succeed by looking after all the people
who aren't that able
they have to accept
uh their position and again working in
japan which is a fascinating country
you've got a very pyramidal structure so
everybody in japan
sort of accepts where they are in a way
they're held back far more than we are
because if you're born into a certain
part of that triangle that's where you
aspire to be
here we don't we should all be
aspirational we should all want to do
well
we have to respect other people we have
to to say well you know he's successful
i should respect him i'd like to emulate
him and i'm going to get off my backside
and do it and i i think there's huge
opportunity here not not least because
of the digital revolution i agree if
anything's holding us back it's
over complicated tax laws which means
you have to employ hugely expensive tax
lawyers and huge expensive lawyers far
too many
lawyers and professionals that they they
need to be trimmed back they're the
fastest
executed
amounts vast amounts of them who are
holding back all these people yeah
because actually if you simplified and
that wouldn't be difficult to get rid of
them or you need to have a flat rate tax
which actually you know has been proved
to work better than all this very
complicated tax law i don't know about
you but i i used to do my own tax return
i now have to rely on an extremely
expensive accountant to do it because
it's so complicated yeah that's
literally what we've had
what the state's done is it's positioned
itself against the individual so it's
trying to rob you without knowing it's
robbed you and then what's it doing
wasting all the money that it takes off
you it was supposed to be spending that
to make your life easier and administer
everything correctly you know your
whatever it was your water your gas your
electricity and the victorians never
privatized all their utilities
because otherwise they got disease and
you know things broke down and people
didn't invest enough
so i think
you know i there's so much that could be
changed so easily
but as you say we've got this we've got
this establishment which is just not fit
for purpose yeah and it's time for
people to start calling them out you
know people the voter
uh the taxpayer should be complaining
you can't get through to hmrc it's so
complicated why do we need all that
complication
the fca they regulate the
the city of london out of existence you
know they worry about a little insider
trader and then they miss
the huge fraud they're never going to
challenge that
so it's all it's all fiddling around at
the lower level
uh again a lot of lawyers and
professionals who are looking at the
small print not the big picture
so i you know that's oppressive you've
got you know as i say that the planners
now are shocking you can't get an answer
at them
they're supposed to uh respond within a
certain time but they don't what's the
sanction if they don't well that doesn't
appear to be one
so uh you know if you the more you
centralize everything and you you saw
this in the ussr you know nothing works
and in the end nobody takes
responsibility and it's always somebody
else's fault
a bit like a bad run football club
my fault
it was him anyway that's enough about
everton
um i'm gonna have to protect you from
anton for the rest of the day
hey francis do you like books i tried
one once wasn't for me mike not enough
pictures of fit brand birds never
working with you again but if you like
fantasy check out the ripples in reality
series by j.s pal they're absolutely
brilliant and they have a five gold star
rating on amazon i've heard of them
they're beautifully written and
completely original if you want a book
that allows you to delve into different
worlds and helps you escape the insanity
of real life then ripples in reality is
for you
see i know the word delve so i do read
books amazing just imagine books written
in the style of game of thrones lord of
the rings forgotten realms with an added
pinch of stargate it's catnip for people
like me virgins
she started a publishing company named
poppy field publishing and her novels
are a massive hit with fans who want to
read books that are a great read and are
not work book one is shadow step
and book two gather shadows
she's currently writing book number
three i can't wait i don't read books
because i can talk to girls your mum
doesn't count mate and by the way js pal
is a big supporter of trigonometry she
is a moderator on our channel and we
really appreciate all her help you can
find her books online at amazonlulu.com
and other bookseller websites if you
enjoy the books please leave a review
the links are in the description
[Music]
the one thing that i wanted to talk to
you about rupert which i think is very
interesting and we we've touched on it
briefly is the future of europe because
we've we've voted to leave and we've
and that was a right that was the right
thing to do that's what the public
wanted i voted remain i believe that we
should have left right that was the
right choice
but you look at the future of europe and
i'm looking at it
and some i don't live there but as
somebody who just
takes a very sort of cursory look at the
place in the countries
it seems to be descending into chaos you
look at what's happening in italy you
look at what's happening in france
you're looking you know locked down
austria germany there's civil rights the
economics is in the toilet
it looks like the end of something well
i i think it's in it's in deep trouble
uh and you know i i the way i explain to
most people who who you know don't want
to get into the detail is the difference
between us and europeans is quite
straightforward so we
we are libertarian free traders and we
have laws
and our laws are structured in such a
way that you know if the law unless the
law says you can't do something you
assume you can that's that's that's the
sort of
to use a politically incorrect phrase
the anglo-saxon view of life
on in europe it's the other way around
yes the europeans and this is this is
how i explain it to people simply the
europeans are the view that unless the
law says you can do it
you assume you can't do it that's the
difference between us the essential
difference in us and them
and you know the european parliament i
think and i i said this to nigel farage
after a day there i said the only reason
i can see this this place exists and
look being there was fun you know you
had lots of debating you had lots of uh
interesting people you had you know and
the concept was fine but actually what
was it there for it was there to stop
germany starting another war with france
and france stopping another war with
germany
and roping everybody together that's
what it's there for
and the european people i think are
suffering i mean i don't understand
i mean varafakis is a man i like i love
reading his books i think he's a very
smart clever again socialist he doesn't
necessarily agree with my view of life
but i respect him as a clever man
you know he would have taken greece out
of the euro i would have taken greece
out of the euro i'd have
gone back to the drachma i'd have
devalued and i'd have made greece the
primary holiday destination of the rest
of europe and it would have rebuilt
itself in no time
but no they got bullied into staying
italy i mean i love italy my wife and i
go walking the via franco jaina in italy
and it's the most fantastic country and
the people are fantastic i love it
they've got style they're great with
children they're kind they fantastic
food
but they're dying on their feet in the
euro so the key
a bit like here the bbc the key cancer
in europe is the euro
so the euro was when they realized that
the political experiment was failing
they thought to themselves we've got to
get
the currency together so without having
if you like the the the the governments
together they they rammed the currency
through and that's why i stood the
referendum party in 97 funded by james
goldsmith he really saved the pound and
50 million pounds he invested
and i i kept my deposit in the cotswolds
uh i got 6.7 of the vote
uh and returned the deposit to sir james
so he saved the pound and the reason we
did that was because
our establishment
shock horror
thought the euro was the best thing
since sliced bread blair famously
yeah all three blair major and patty
ashdown yeah all wanted it so you know
but then we got this promise of a
referendum which in the end um
uh and again everybody says oh it's it
was it was gordon brown had nothing to
do with goldman the referendum party
came before gordon brown we'd have been
in the euro if if we if jimmy hadn't got
i think he got eight hundred and
twenty thousand votes or something
uh i know because i had a bet with
somebody with a foreigner of a case of
champagne you said we wouldn't get half
a million votes so that put enough
pressure on them to
promise all three parties promised a
referendum which is why cameron had a
referendum in the end didn't need to
have it when he did but he did because
he was arrogant enough that he was going
to win it
so i think you know europe's been killed
by the euro
and the euro must fail
but it's a bit like the ussr you know
once you've got this elite that's
all in
it's never going to admit defeat until
and again the the communist bloc was so
rotten when it fell there was nothing
there everybody everybody thought i
remember the wall coming down everybody
thought it would take 10 years took a
nanosecond because there was nothing
left
it was rotten and you're going to see
that i think in europe so it'll it it'll
last longer than you think but when it
fails it'll fail spectacularly
and that's when
the real truth about this
post-war protectionist block which is
what they are you know from the common
agricultural policy right the way
through it's completely protectionist
it's totally anti everything that that
really we we stand for as a trading
nation
um but we lost our confidence we went in
you know we had ted heath
and a bunch of really quite weak leaders
then i mean it's not new this weak
leader business
and they took us in because they lost
confidence
and we then had maggie as you know
maggie was very euroskeptic but i think
there's a real shock coming in europe at
some stage
but how long can italy go on
i liken it to withering on the vine i
mean they literally the blood supply is
being cut off and they're sort of
withering
and they can't thrive until they're out
of the euro but this is what i don't
understand i've never been in business
right but but i look how can you have
the same currency for economies as
diverse as germany
italy
greece they're completely different
economies with different needs look
there's only one solution the which is
the counter-intuitive solution and you
may know the germans never wanted to
join the euro they got they got bullied
by the french into joining and in fact
in fact the germans yeah the germans
wanted to keep the deutsche mark in fact
they've i used to work for deutsche bank
so they ultimately they they were
bullied into joining they've been the
main beneficiary of it so the
counterintuitive resolution to this is
for germany to leave the euro
and leave all the weak nations and let
the euro float down that'll net that
again this elite that's sort of holding
it all together won't let that happen
that's what they should be doing if they
want to protect the
living standards of the majority of the
people in europe but i mean i'm i'm
amazed at how servile most of the
european electorate is they are
incredibly servile and again look at
their history
uh you know they tend to be
far less questioning than us
far less individualistic far less
libertarian and that's ultimately i
think the the root cause of the problem
between us and france has always been a
problem and i always will be
and of course that difference in
attitude you see reflected in the covert
restrictions the way that you know even
even though i think all three of us have
complained pretty hard about the things
that have happened here and i think a
lot of them been very wrong the vaccine
passports for example just outrageous as
far as i'm concerned outrageous
outrageous but
how far they've gone on the continent
it's a different scale well matt
macron's behaving like a dictator right
and look at us yeah and yet the cases in
france are getting through the roof and
funnily enough in in the most jabbed
country in the world israel yeah the
stats don't bear looking at i mean
they're still jabbing away
and and sagitte jabbit as i like to call
him he he he's trying he's trying to
emulate them or he was at one time i i
might pinch that from you if you don't
mind rasage
but uh look there's one thing that we've
got about ten minutes left and there's
one thing that we haven't talked about
yet which is interesting to me and i
think interesting to a lot of people
what is it like to be involved in
football what is it like to run a
football club
well as i said earlier i got into
football by default so i was i was going
to
build the football stadium saint mary's
which we did build in the end again we
had huge trouble with local councils so
just to give you a quick example of how
inefficient uh the local politics of
these various places is originally we
were going to build the stadium right
next to the airport so it would have
been a fantastic site so you had
hampshire county council council was a
tory council
southampton city council was labour
and eastly borough council was liberal
so none of them could agree that water
was wet
and
the site should have been the site where
we developed the stadium and we would
have built it and developed it and
project managed it for nothing just to
have the stadium but no
they couldn't agree so in the end
southampton city council for their
credit helped us it was the old trance
ghost site so we had to spend a fortune
uh cleaning up all the
oil residue and then we had to do the
archaeology which was interesting
because it's on the ancient settlement
of hamwick so we did find some quite
interesting trading relics because we've
always been traders with northern europe
so that it's very interesting we found
lots of stuff there which we put on on
show in the stadium so we've built some
areas
but i had no idea when i got when we did
the reverse takeover and i became
chairman of the holding company and guy
asked him who's a fantastic man my
previous chairman
he was remain chairman of the football
club and then we were going to be
relegated
uh and we we had i think uh 27 points
from 31 games
we were bottom
and guy asked him said to me you need to
be chairman of both companies to uh
bring some sense and rationalization
when we go down and we lose a lot of the
premier league income so i thought well
i'm not going to do that without having
a bit of a bit of a fight so shock
horror unlike any chairman before i
started getting to the dressing room
because i as i said i used to play
reasonably competitive hockey and i'm
not trying to address them
and cut a long story short we in the in
those final seven games we we we got i
think 13 points
uh because we know 14 points we ended up
i think with 41 points from memory
and if you remember i think middleton
went down that year and we stayed up
and that's when sue neston resigned
and i was then uh uh then lauren
mcmenemy resigned uh having stitched me
up so twenty first of all soon as i said
well if you're gonna go laurie you
resigned together
but no he we wrote the press release
together lauren menomi says this and
then 24 hours later lori resigned and
then there's me
on virtually every back page of most
tabloids looking like a child molester
with a border running around it saying
southampton crisis
so i just shut the phones off and in the
end uh you know i hired um
dave jones
and
we
didn't do very well to start with i had
the whole stadium i i think the joke at
southampton after the first
10 games of that season i think we had
one point and the joke going around was
what's the difference between
southampton and a cocktail stick the
answer to which is a cocktail stick's
got two points
so and the
crowd with chanting rupert
[Music]
i thought what am i doing mm-hmm right
anyway then it all came right now sorry
to interrupt because it's fascinating
what is that like because stressful no
one in very few people even we we get a
lot of hate online from everybody right
but that's different that's different
when it's online i can go this person's
sitting in their mother's basement they
haven't but you've got fifty thousand
people they've paid fifteen and a half
thousand at the deal yeah but let's say
i told my wife it wasn't true
and i had to pretend i i i i i wasn't
affected by it which i you have to show
outwardly no no no sign of but there's
15 000 people who've paid 25 quid
in your own stadium i think we lost two
nil to leeds that it was an evening game
anyway
then we i remember
christopher bland was at the get next
game we were playing west ham and the
the punters were lobbing you know their
their programs at us and christopher
bland got hit on the shoulder by a
projectile this is west ham
and we beat west ham three nil and then
we didn't look back we beat liverpool
and anfield and by christmas i think we
were
11th in the league or something so it
all calmed down the best i ever got
uh being as they called me a toff and a
public school boy was
being left alone if we were doing well
which on the whole we did
so um
the so we
what do i think of football i loved it
because i'm i'm competitive i love sport
i now play reasonably good tennis
because i'm getting too old to you know
charge around a hockey pitch or football
pitch
um but i loved it i mean it's the best
thing and probably the best day of my
life was going to uh the millennium
stadium in cardiff when we got to the
cup final and we we lost one nil to
arsenal but you you'd think from our
fans that we'd won we should have won i
mean i you know uh little brett ormworld
hit the post i think and had we got
arsenal actually weren't on form that
day but they won one
but so we built it i built the youth
academy because we were never going to
be able to compete because football's
like war you have to have a big economy
so the stadium gave us a bigger economy
uh you know we got we we now we used to
fill saint mary's which is 32 000 uh
seats 32 and a half but we could we had
to because of health and safety we had
to separate lost few seats
um
so and we got stronger and stronger you
know got to the cut final
i hired clive which i thought was a
stroke of genius but i got butchered in
the media
and then bizarrely the fans
didn't hold
they don't tend to hold their
i never like to call them managers i
like to call them head coaches because
that's ultimately that's the correct uh
that's what they do
um so i built the academy up i loved the
academy and we got some great young
players like walcott and bale and shaw
and oxlade-chamberlain and lallana and
you know it goes on and on so we we
trained these people i brought a coach
in from france for the academy
i bought in procurement we went around
finding people from all the best people
from club so i rather than buying
success we were trying to
train success but that's not what the
industry wants because it's quite
corrupt and lots of people make lots of
money out of it so
you know the big clubs like to dominate
it they don't mind the odd cup victory
of a little club it's quite romantic but
they don't like it if the little clubs
start to do too well
and that model wouldn't work for them
because actually
you've only got 11 people on the pitch
and if they're trained properly and
they're mentally prepared properly
there's no reason why they can't roll
over
people who spend a lot more money
but they control it because
if you're if your little kids go out
onto the pitch
at old trafford
and they the previous week it's been
about you know wonderful manchester
united and struggling southampton a lot
of football is one off the pitch
these guys go out on the pitch they
don't believe they're going to win so
they don't win
and you know that so the dominance of
the big clubs is
it's almost a tribal thing you know and
you go your children go to a football
school so my little kids were the only
two in saints outfits
so probably maybe six or seven menu five
arsenal some liverpool and they'd all
they'd all you know take the michael out
of the little southampton lads so that's
how it's it's all sort of again it's
collectivism it's it's it's that's what
it's become
uh so i loved it and it's in terribly
corrupt industry
uh why is it
let's let's go into it so how is it
correct how is it
it's corrupt because it's dominated by
the agents
i always wanted the premier league to
make it illegal for
an agent to collect a fee from both a
club and a player
and if the player retained the agent he
should pay the agent but no the big
clubs didn't want that because they
could pay the agents far more
than the little clubs so they ended up
getting the players they wanted so
there's all sorts of stuff that goes on
in there
and it's it is
trust me it's terribly corrupt and it's
disappointing because it's such
it's such an important uh uh
game for so many people in the country
and it you sort of hope it might be
honest and you sort of hope it might be
structured properly
but then you look at the premier league
now i mean it's gone woke i i don't
understand why
you know all this business of taking the
knee that shouldn't be for the premier
league to push that stuff that should be
that should actually be for the
individual not the premier league why
not ruth but some people might say and
again playing devil's advocate that they
might say well look uh a lot of y'all
quite a part of the fact that blm is a
fairly bad organization
there's no disagreement here about that
but that's not my point my point is
that's your personal view and it's my
personal view and it's probably france's
personal view but
forgetting about the organization a lot
of people might say this is the argument
that people i think often put forward is
that the
footballers are hugely respected by
young people in particular and what they
do and how they conduct themselves as
role models for for others is important
and this is a huge opportunity to
address this important social issue i
think you can address it in a much
better way i mean i mean the truth is
that a lot of
young footballers the biggest problem
they have is when they start to earn
money and they they go off the rails a
bit and you know far more important to
put a structure around them and try and
protect them from that if you can
i i again i think the blm taking the
knee is as you know a lot of the black
players didn't want to do that because
they thought it was
it wasn't right they should do it
so you know there were some people who
took objection to it i really i
personally think it's not i think they
devalued their brand by doing it i don't
think it's up to them i think quite
apart from that blm is a bad
organization anyway
uh and i don't think this country is
racist i don't think we need that to be
underlined so therefore
you know i don't think that should be
shoved down people's throats it's a bit
like being told you've got to wear a
mask or you've got to have a vaccine
pass border it's all part of this
prescriptive society that has its roots
in health and safety and all the other
stuff i mean i look obviously one needs
to take care
to protect people but to treat them like
numpties and you know legislate a lot of
this stuff comes from the sort of the
health and safety and
in the in the end you and i are
responsible for our own health and
safety that's
that's how it always used to be and if
you aren't clever enough if you're too
stupid to look after yourself in the end
you're going to get hurt
so it's all about individual empowerment
and it's about individual decision
making that's what we've got to release
here we've got great people
but if you cow them
uh and they all behave like you know as
i say the the the sort of
reverse darwinist plan
uh then you'll destroy this innate uh
creativity and entrepreneurialism i
we've got to uh allow the libertarian
agenda to to to
to to remain here
well collectivism must be allowed to
succeed
on that happy note our time is up thank
you so much for coming in we have as
always just one more question for you
before we do our special questions for
our locals only supporters so here we go
uh and the last question is always
what's the one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be
uh farming
tell us more well i farming is an
incredibly important part of the country
we we have a great farming industry
uh there aren't enough young people
going into it there's not enough
encouragement uh to produce our own food
here food security is incredibly
important
uh we're an island as we've seen with
gas you know if you
don't make the use
of your own innate reserves and
resources you end up relying on on mr
putin and russia for your gas
so again a bit like the the the supply
of gas farming needs it needs more
attention more planning more support
and british farming is one of our
most successful uh industries which is
often overlooked
that is very very interesting and in
fact we're currently looking at a few
guests to come on to talk to us about
farming so thank you rupert if people
want to find you online where is the
best place to do that i'm i'm at rupert
lowe 10 on twitter
and i'm at roop at low 10 because when i
went on to twitter at nigel farage's
insistence when i stood for the brexit
party i found there were nine saints
fans who'd plagiarized my twitter
very good
all right well thank you so much for
coming on and thank you all for watching
and listening we'll see you very soon
with another brilliant episode like this
one or raw show all of them go out at
7pm uk time and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
so manderick had sent me a rotting duck
a bit like the mafia
because i wouldn't let redneck go it
arrived